there's a lot of funds out there betting
on Tech so you can believe the broad
market and the economy with it are going
to have tough times and a recession and
things going on you can believe that at
the same time you believe but I think
Tech's going to be okay remember when
gas prices are up the oils oil stocks
were doing pretty well was that price
gouging you can have that debate another
time but there's an example of something
that looks bad oh my gosh heating oil
you know average people paying for gas
in their cars to commute bad news oil
stocks up good news there's always
losing kind of a balancing effect in all
this